ماذا تفعل اذا داهمك زلزال في المنزل او
في الشارع او في السياره
اذا كنت في المنزل حاول الحفاظ على هدوءك
انزل على يديك وركبتيك فهذه الوضعيه تحميك
من السقوط وتسمح لك بالحركه اذا لزم الامر
قم بتغطيه راسك ورقبتك وجسمك بالكامل ان
امكن اسفل الطاوله او مكتبا قوي واذا لم
يكن هناك ماوى قريب انزل قريبا من الجدار
او بجوار اثاث منخفض لا يقع عليك وغطي
راسك ورقبتك بذراعيك ويدك ابقى في مكانك
ثابتا حتى يتوقف الاهتزاز
اذا كنت في الداخل وابقى مكانك ولا ترقد
الى الخارج او الى غرفه اخرى اثناء
الزلزال فستكون اقل عرضه للاصابه اذا بقيت
في مكانك لا تستخدم المصاعد او الدرج اذا
كان في حاله سيئه
[موسيقى]
واذا كنت في الخارج ابتعد عن الاعمده
الكهربائيه والاشجار والمباني والاشياء
المتساقطه تجنب التدافع والركض خارج
المباني ابقى في الخارج حتى تتوقف الهزه
واعلم ان احد اخطر الاماكن هو قرب مخارج
المباني مباشره
اذا كنت تقود سيارتك فعليك التوقف فورا
الى جانب الطريق تجنب الوقوف تحت الجسور
او خطوط واعمده الكهرباء او المباني
والاشجار قد تهتز السياره بعنف على
نوابضها لكنها مكان جيد للبقاء حتى يتوقف
الاهتزاز
عند انتهاء الزلزال تفقد من حولك وعند
وجود مصابين تفقد حالتهم الصحيه وحاول
تقديم الاسعافات الاوليه لهم ولا تستخدم
هاتفك الا للضروره القسوه للحفاظ على شحن
البطاريه اطول فتره ممكنه وتابع اخبار
وارشادات الجهات الرسميه عبر الراديو او
الانترنت او وسائل الاعلام المتوفره